so when I walked into the screening for
dirty grandpa they handed me this and I
thought oh okay it's a matchbook because
De Niro likes to smoke cigars in the
movie no it's actually a condom dirty
grandpa stars Robert De Niro and Zac
Efron and is the story of a grandson
taking his grieving grandfather on a
road trip when he discovers his good old
grandpa isn't exactly as clean as he
thought he was so when I walked into the
screening and they handed me a frickin
condom I was like I'm in for something
here better prepare myself there's good
and bad and dirty grandpa let's talk
about the good for one Robert De Niro is
hilarious here he does an excellent job
and him and Zac Efron have really good
chemistry they work really well with one
another as a comedic team Believe It or
Not Efron plays a straight man whereas
De Niro's the more goofy over-the-top
character that's not something I
expected to see going into this movie
because I didn't watch any of the
trailers De Niro was the most
foul-mouthed he's ever been in a movie
he's more offensive than he's ever been
in a movie let me just say this if
you're an easily offended person if you
often find yourself going that's
offensive to me uh yeah I don't see
dirty grandpa because pretty much every
single offensive joke you could possibly
imagine is in this movie there are times
where that works because the movie goes
for this kind of shock value and
sometimes it's very funny and it really
hits and then there are times where it
just comes off desperate and some of the
writing does not work I must stress the
two main stars Efron and De Niro really
made this movie mostly watchable what I
hated about this movie are a few very
annoying side characters that get way
too much screen time like this drug
dealer who keeps showing up who after a
while just became very tiresome and I
didn't find him funny at all and also
his story makes no sense it's a comedy
in which things happen that would never
occur in real life ever and it's purely
for the sake of a joke it's almost like
the story of this movie purely exists
just to set our main characters into
over-the-top outrageous scenes and it
just begins to lose focus after some
time there's also a very annoying cousin
character who's in way too much of the
movie and those two annoying characters
the drug dealer
cousin character just graded on my
nerves so much the comedy just felt so
flat for those characters and there are
moments where the movie almost feels
like a fantasy and it becomes hard to
have that suspension of disbelief when
you're watching this movie even though
it is funny from time to time because so
many things occur that just make no
sense and it makes our characters feel
more like Domino pieces than actual
people all positioned in just the right
way to topple over to get us to a
punchline and that's what the majority
of dirty grandpa felt like to me a
string of outrageous scenes that
sometimes work but after a while just
get so tired because so much of it just
doesn't feel like it would actually
happen look if you just want to go see a
movie that will probably make you laugh
this movie will probably make you laugh
but if you want a more coherent film
where scenes don't feel like just scenes
that are set up like an SNL skit with a
joke at the end you want an actual story
that flows and make sense filled with
characters that you can grow attached to
and you laugh with them because well
they're funny and this story is funny
the dirty grandpa probably is not the
movie for you because it purely exists
to tell a bunch of dirty jokes and while
some of them are funny the actual movie
beneath all those jokes made no sense to
me and the narrative was very messed up
I'm gonna give dirty grandpa a C so guys
you may have noticed that behind me is a
bunch of tomb raider merchandise I also
mentioned this in my review for the
fifth wave well that's because I
recently filmed my review of tomb raider
with Angelina Jolie and that's going to
be a hilarious 'ti review that goes up
this Sunday it's my biggest guilty
pleasure movie of all time
and I had so much fun talking about it I
can't wait to share that with you guys
I'm also going to be reviewing the boy
and I'll have that review very soon you
guys are the best thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my eyes